[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir Mathilde alors je
le rappelle vous êtes conseillère
municipal en charge du bien-être animal
pour la ville de Poissy et ce soir vous
allez nous parler des lapins et vous
êtes venus avec une lapine alors un
lapin en fait un lapin cannelle donc je
suis venue accompagnée de cannelle qui
est un peu craintif ce soir elle a
entendu parler de chenille à poils c'est
un peu donc elle a une particularité
c'est qu'elle mord les vêtements et ce
soir voilà j'ai ramené aussi son petit
coussin ou à la un petit peu mordu et
mais par contre il faut surtout pas la
punir un lapin ne doit pas être punition
et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle mord les
vêtements ou les tissus à leur Athis
alors elle fait ses dents et puis aussi
c'est un signe où elle a besoin de
caresses d'accord et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ne faut jamais punir un lapin
alors le lapin en fait c'est un animal
qui est très intelligent il apprend très
vite il n'a pas besoin qu'on ose la voix
mais également très craintif donc il
faut l'encourager le motiver en fait il
faut être comme un coach d'équipe pour
pouvoir la motiver et puis le vous
rendra très bien alors est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres choses à savoir sur le
caractère du lapin alors le lapin il est
très doux il est très sociable c'est un
animal en fait qui a été un animal de
domestiqué à partir du 15e siècle on
l'appelle le NAC aujourd'hui le nouvel
animal de compagnie c'est un animal donc
qui est agréable à vivre si la confiance
en vous il vit en groupe et pour marquer
son territoire donc lui est une proie il
va marquer son territoire avec de
l'urine avec de la grotte et avec autre
glande
à l'âge de la maturité sexuelle il va
être agressif donc il est conseillé de
le stériliser entre 6 et 12 mois
d'accord et ce qu'il y a des choses
aussi à prendre en compte si on souhaite
adopter un lapin au niveau de son
habitat par exemple oui alors au niveau
de son habitat donc je conseille une
très grande cage pour qu'il ait une cage
en hauteur pour qu'il ait la place pour
ses pattes arrières qui soit dans le
calme et il est diurne donc le soir
ouvrir sa cage pour qu'il puisse faire
son petit tour et puis bien protégé vos
meubles et les câbles de vos téléphones
fixes si vous en avez encore et pareil
est-ce qu'il faut savoir des choses sur
son entretien oui concernant son
entretien donc vérifiez bien ses
oreilles ses yeux et surtout sa
dentition donc s'il avait des problèmes
au niveau de l'occlusion il aurait des
difficultés à s'alimenter bien le
brosser bien sûr pour éviter les
parasites et puis en période de mue
aussi et surtout bah on voit un lapin
c'est c'est mignon c'est tellement
mignon qu'on croit à chaque fois que
c'est une femelle
c'est pas une peluche parce que cannelle
a une histoire particulière en fait elle
a été ça a été un achat compulsif d'une
famille avec plusieurs enfants en bas
âge à la lettre abandonnée la forêt donc
là j'ai demandé à la personne de nous
l'apporter en mairie de Poissy cannelle
est arrivé à l'accueil et notre agent de
la ville de Poissy qui s'appelle
Virginie que je salue la immédiatement
adoptée et bien sûr elle s'appuie sur
ses filles
Océane et Morgan qui s'en occupent avec
très grande responsabilité donc je tiens
à aller féliciter et aller saluer merci
encore
Océane et Morgane et alors que
manges-t-il ce lapin à part les
vêtements du coup
alors il est herbivore c'est un très bon
exemple pour les enfants et pour les
maris ils mangent des légumes
ils mangent des Brooks
des épinards par contre il a une
particularité et c'est qui mange
également ses crottes d'accord en fait
la digestion elle se passe très
rapidement il n'a pas le temps de faire
cette digestion et un deuxième passage
donc il attrape ses crottes au niveau de
la nuque qui sont encore molles et
humides qui sont bourrés de vitamine B
de protéines c'est quelque chose donc si
votre lapin se comportement là il ne
faut pas s'inquiéter c'est un
comportement qui est tout à fait normal
d'où également de vérifier le poids de
votre lapin s'il est en surpoids il va
avoir du mal à les récupérer et ses
crottes au niveau de l'anus à savoir
c'est une information assez insolite
voilà et également cette année comme
vous le savez c'est l'année du lapin
pour en Chine le lapin à symbolise la
paix la prospérité il n'est pas trop
tard pour vous souhaiter à tous une très
bonne année du lapin il y a un bon année
du lapins à vous aussi merci beaucoup
pour tous ces conseils et toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouve
prochainement pour une autre chronique
bien-être oui vous me trouvez
prochainement avec un autre invité je
dis peut-être une tortue ça va dépendre
de son planning d'accord et ben on a
hâte de voir ça en tout cas